do you know when the voice is gonna
speak sometimes and when it does does it
feel like it's coming from inside you
you know you know it's coming from
behind me I got being used does it ever
say things just to you that only you can
hear what does it say it said he wants
to hurt you
when did it say that right now we were
very close-knit family we was good
children we had no knowledge of the
history of the house before the
happenings
I remember ed saying we'll go we'll go
it's Enfield oh it no no no oh honey I'm
dead no give my yeah with a long time oh
no no yeah yeah we actually go out to
the neighborhood that there was
something strange going on in our house
and then it became known as a strange
happenings in EM field
I was used and abused there was
levitation there was divorces she didn't
say I can do a quite life frightening
for me with the Warrens out of their
repertoire of cases that they have
investigated of their lifetime the
haunting of the Hudson family is what
are their most interesting ones do you
know when the horse is gonna speak
sometimes what does it say it said he
wants to have you Janet Hodgson was at
the epicenter of one of the most witness
and longest case of poltergeist activity
you're constantly going it really did
happen for these people that really did
happen you see what happened wasn't good
I needed to help them the emotions the
thought of it I think if I had to go for
it Kenny it killed me
this is Peggy Peggy Hodgson nice to meet
you Hawaii it's my wife Lorene well I'll
be off homepage you tell the kids I'll
settle oh yeah coach well nice to meet
you you too hon so here we are Peggy
what do come in it's just me and Janet
here now miles our kids are staying with
them this is where the girls used to
sleep but we don't use anymore
well most of the activity centered in
this room we were quite afraid that
someone might get hurt which is why we
keep it locked I understand that Janet
is levitated did that happen in here as
well at more than once and you've got
photographs of that as well I'd like to
hear mrs. Hodgson story from her if you
don't wait
the neighbors donated them and I'll hang
them up hope and I keep things from
moving around as it worked no we can
hear all night
hey no it no yeah
now
now I'm a girl
yes yes okay
how does it feel living in a haunted
house you don't get used to it safely
wait was someone more family before this
it's been getting worse since mr. grouse
started talking to it I wonder what
would happen if we tried talking to it
now is anybody there
is anybody there who wishes to
communicate Janet
Spahn sleep and I'm talking what is your
name this is my home this is my no this
is not your house now what's your name
my name is Bell welcome and I'm Shannon
key kid again what do you make of that
forest sounds confused you see that the
voice on this tape is coming from an
eleven year old girl they're calling it
England's Amityville there is a family
that desperately needs our help
after everything we've seen there isn't
much that rattles either of us anymore
but this one this one still wants me
does it feel like Anna voices coming
from inside you when is coming from
behind me my god being used
Jannetty alright sharbat she's such a
good course they were without an
oppressing spirit will trying to enforce
you to commit the ultimate sin
what's that murder suicide or both you
believe us them sensing a presence I'm
not sensing anything all I can sense is
their own fear
let me relate it what is happening I had
a premonition of your death
the family's just a pawn
something inhuman wants to kill you
if we keep doing this
you're going to die
no this is not your house
now what's your name no doc very well
who's that bill bill bill bill bill who
my name is bill welcome and I'm Jevon
kikuyo
what do you make of that voice sounds
confused see see now the voice on this
tape is coming from an 11-year old girl
have you two been playing with this
taking turns scaring the Wits out of
each other no wonder I can't get a good
night's sleep
I don't want to hear another word now
get back to bed are you